somewhat literally us humans are split
right down the middle
divided by the dichotomy of our own
nature on the left side our brain
generally operates out of reason and
logic and on the right it generally
operates out of emotion and feeling both
sides work for their cause and typically
depending on the brain and the situation
both sides can work together but what is
most interesting and potentially very
problematic is when they do not when
both sides are unable to find common
ground leaving us hopelessly confused
and distressed when working together our
logical brain rationalizes our emotions
and our emotional brain inspires our
logic oftentimes this can be successful
and create great synergy but other times
there seems to be no successful bridging
between the two one example of this that
can cause us to feel a sense of deep
confusion and alienation from ourselves
is when our emotions and feelings become
so layered and complex that they cannot
be rationalized with or successfully
articulated by the logical side of our
brain as strange as it may seem it is
possible to experience two very
conflicting feelings simultaneously it
is possible to feel both angry with
someone for saying something cruel to
you but simultaneously sad that they
feel that way about you
it is possible to feel both excited
about a career opportunity but scared of
it at the same time it is possible to
feel both happy about an amazing moment
or memory but also sad that it is or
will soon be gone
it is possible to love someone for being
perfect for you but simultaneously hate
them for not loving you back and each
pairing creates its own separate unique
feeling very different from the feeling
of their individual counterparts it is
like tasting a sweet and sour sauce
although there are both sweet
ingredients and sour ingredients the
blended flavor is really neither sweet
nor sour it is its own separate and
unique flavor and the blending of our
emotions works just the same furthermore
it is possible to feel a mix of several
emotions that don't really distill down
to our this and our that but rather an
array of pushes and pulls and ups and
downs in every which direction creating
a feeling of indescribable numbness that
can not even be pinpointed on a reason
for feeling it a feeling of confusion
despair or overwhelm for no apparent
reason from a logical perspective how is
it possible that we can feel two or more
opposing emotions at the same time
simply it is because we can and because
we do
life and our emotional experience of it
is not always black and white
and it is not always logically
discernible there are innumerable shades
of emotional gray area some that our
logical eye can distinguish some that it
cannot and when we cannot discern or
classify a feeling what do we do quite
naturally we become confused and
overwhelmed our ability to make
decisions changes or simply understand
our self and feel normal or become
impaired but we must accept that despite
how hard it tries our brain does not yet
fully understand itself and therefore
neither can we as we continue to evolve
and learn as a species perhaps we will
be able to better understand and define
the depth of gray area that resides
between our left and right self perhaps
we will better understand what we feel
why we feel the things we feel and how
to better articulate and deal with them
but until then we must acknowledge and
accept that there are things that we
cannot control or understand about
ourselves but we should not feel alone
or abnormal because of this
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder